as the fight to contain a global
pandemic continues
several new variants of the covert 19
virus are spreading
early research suggests these so-called
mutations are more infectious
and potentially deadlier one variant
first discovered in the uk and another
in south africa
are now the focus of modena's efforts to
develop a booster injection
the company says its original vaccine
does fight the uk variant of the virus
but there are questions about the
mutated strain
discovered in south africa i'm hearing
reports
that there may be some concern about the
south african variant that there's
a reduction in the ability of the
vaccine to neutralize
the virus i'm hearing a six-fold
reduction we'll see if that's confirmed
that is some concern but it still will
likely
cross protect out of an abundance of
caution modena says it's now working on
an alternative version of its vaccine
the company says its original vaccine
does give antibodies above levels that
are expected to be protective
against the south african variant but
it's a sign of the shape-shifting nature
of the virus
dr anthony fauci says the entire medical
community
needs to adapt okay so even though right
now
the vaccines seem to be able to work
against them
we need to be prepared to upgrade and
maybe even as a boost
later on or as a bivalent vaccine
that goes against both the wild type and
the evolving mutants
in a bid to contain the variance the
biden administration has reimposed a
travel ban on non-us citizens
the ban will prohibit travelers from the
uk island and 26 nations in europe as
well as brazil
and south africa with the pandemic
worsening and more contagions
variant contagious variants spreading
this isn't the time to be lifting
restrictions on international travel
and in light of the contagious variant
uh b1351
south africa has been added to the
restricted list
from tuesday other international
travelers to the u.s must test
negative for covert 19 before boarding
their flight
as the covert 19 virus continues to
mutate companies like modernist say
it's vital they stay proactive in the
fight against the pandemic
the company and others say their
original vaccines do provide protection
but they want to make sure people get
updated vaccines
before things potentially get worse andy
gallacher al jazeera
miami florida